I'm starting to panic a little bit my
body's in a lot of pain it just tries to
summon I'm feeling great you're not a
pain and I'm walking I sure as hell hope
I finished the marathon hi I'm Morgan
and I will be running the New York City
Marathon in 30 days so I work out pretty
frequently everything from
high-intensity interval training to
Pilates yoga a whole mix of things so
both my parents are athletes and I've
run many marathons and triathlons I was
never a runner training for the marathon
hasn't made me love running and I've
never understood the runner's high so I
worked really closely with a charity
called Smile Train and they provide
cleft palate and lip surgeries to
children globally they came into my
office where I work and they were
talking about ways to get involved one
of the ways was running the New York
City Marathon growing up in New York my
entire life I watched the marathon every
year I loved watching it every year
almost I would walk away like in tears
so inspired by the runners and I always
said I'm gonna do it one day I'm gonna
do it one day and this year the
opportunity just actually presented
itself to me I have notoriously a lot of
injuries from dancing my entire life so
I have a really bad back I have bad
knees I'm just not set up to run a
marathon but the first reaction of
everyone who I know was like I don't
think that you should be running the
marathon my boyfriend was like you need
to go see your your knee surgeon
immediately before you commit to
something like this just the idea of
getting like past that finish line is
what's motivating me to get through so
prior to training for the marathon I
have been going to workout classes or
the gym five to six times a week now my
schedule is really shifting so that I'm
running three to four times a week and
then doing strength training to make
sure that everything else is supporting
me throughout the race I sure as hell
hope I finish the marathon I will be
crawling across the finish line if I
have to hold this whether I run I'm
having it no more
so when I first started training for the
marathon my back was starting to ache my
knees would really bother me after even
the 3 mile runs with the five mile runs
I am in Florence Italy seeing the city
climbing not I'm starting to integrate
longer runs into my training other
injuries are starting to come up so I
got back from a trip last night really
and it's just been a really hard for me
to run I gotten really certainty about
the marathon so my foot is really
starting to bother me I'm trying to
focus on getting prepared mentally for
that to happen time he ran off look it's
hurting by knowing that I don't have to
finish and some crazy time I don't need
to finish in like four hours or even
four and a half hours or officially it's
three weeks after marathon I'm starting
to panic a little bit because my Lakshmi
my left foot are really bothering me at
long runs and I have my longest run
coming up this weekend before I start
tapering off distance and I just don't
know I'm gonna make it across the finish
line at this point okay we're heading
out for a four mile run today and I'm
feeling pretty good pretty motivated
because I hit my fundraiser last night
would only get off with our so learning
got there and 16 days out from the
marathon and hang out for a three-mile
and for my long run to look at my last
run my other T runs this week my foot
hasn't been bothering me as much gonna
go for three today before my long run
tomorrow and then I'm done with long
runs until the big day counting every
last mile it can be really grueling
throughout the training process we are
heading out for fifteen miles today yeah
this is gonna be my longest on the my
entire training because I but maybe me
are just not great if I can get to mile
23 with adrenaline and was a thousands
of people who I'm surrounded by then I
think that I can I can make it those
last three miles and be really proud of
myself when I cross the finish line so I
haven't run since my 15 mile run on
Saturday
my body's in a lot of pain so from that
you will see how this goes I have a
couple of short runs left running ins
Hudson 3 miles a day so marathon Wow we
will officially started the seven day
countdown to the marathon
I'm not feeling super great about it my
knee is really bothering me six day
countdown heading out for a 5k whew I
pick up my bed
it's getting real there are 48 hours
from the race and not feeling great
about it I woke up several times last
night because I had fears that I what
I'm not gonna fish the last 24 hours
have been kind of a whirlwind of emotion
and starting to have a lot of doubts
about the race itself not finishing
finishing last so I'm not here running
three final miles 48 hours before the
actual marathon and I'm just gonna take
it easy the rest of the weekend and try
to gain my confidence back I can't
believe it's finally here I am headed to
a marathon and I just have a lot of
nerves and I'm feeling the adrenaline
didn't sleep trying to conceptualize and
wrap my head around running 26.2 miles
was always really tough for me just
being in this crowd of people in the
marathon village where you're surrounded
by thousands and thousands of people
like there I'm the star line really
excited and seeing all of them preparing
and seeming like they all knew that what
they were doing and here I was someone
who had never run more than 15 miles and
that was only in my training not even
knowing like what to wear or what things
to come prepared with it just hasn't
finished home when I was just trying to
convince myself to start the race really
really really slow and even then I
started and went too fast bring a little
bit too fast
turnin piece I just trust my house on it
nobody see my friends and having people
there to cheer me on and being able to
actually stop because I wasn't timing
myself for the marathon to spend time
and just take in all of the interactions
with my friends and family who came out
to see me was so so important to me just
gone over the Queensboro Bridge at Mile
20 I really had a wall when I hit the
Bronx I didn't have any friends or
family there to cheer me on he's really
wrong a lot of pain right now
tapasya once I hit mile 22 I saw my
friends and family again and I couldn't
even stop to say hi to them
I just go back in time yet in the end
that's a great lot of pain I'm walking I
wanted to break down and cry I wanted to
quit the race all right I see that yeah
on to the final nine once I hit mile 23
and I was in Central Park
I felt the adrenaline I was able to run
again [ __ ] it I felt like my legs
kind of went numb to help me get to the
end of the race 25 nine way to go having
so many people cheering you on as the
Sun was going down and just the buzz was
absolutely amazing
my biggest challenge I think was just
wrapping my head around finishing the
marathon getting past that finish line
was really really hard to do but it was
really the krug that carried me through
and it's really just the willpower of
knowing that I could get past another
mile and another and another and another
it's like I could cry thinking about
crossing the finish line again Wow just
the feeling of crossing that finish line
and then going and grabbing a medal from
someone and then being handed your
poncho and being allowed out of the park
with all these other finishers was
completely surreal after I went home and
I parked myself on my couch and ordered
a Shake Shack burger and french fries
and a milkshake and I continued to eat
for the next 48 hours straight I had
about seven meals the next day I think I
would run the New York City Marathon
again being a New Yorker and being able
to run through the boroughs and
represent the city and be among the
crowds of all of the people who are on
the sidelines and the other runners it's
such an amazing feeling weirdly I think
I do love running so I'm trying to be
realistic about my feelings and that I
still am in the post marathon hi we'll
see if if I'm inspired still in January
if you're considering a marathon just go
for it it's really terrifying to see
that distance
and even look at the route and idealize
yourself running through all of those
places especially when you're going
through training and you don't have the
crowds and you don't have any of the
cheering or any of the adrenaline but it
really is the most rewarding feeling in
the entire world knowing that you
accomplished that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]